-Also happening next week,
I have a new children's book
coming out on Tuesday called
"Con Pollo."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I wrote it with Jennifer Lopez.
It's a fun this-or-that book
that helps you
teach your kids
how to speak Spanish.
-[ Speaking Spanish ]
-Oh, my --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Rosita -- Rosita,
what are you doing here?
Why are you not on
"Sesame Street"?
-Oh, Jimmy, you have a new look.
-I do.
-Yeah, you're starting to look
like you're Pancho.
The monster in you
is coming out.
-It's coming out.
I'm getting furry. Yeah.
-But you know what?
I heard about your new book,
and yo hablo Español --
I speak Spanish.
I'm so excited.
And I'm learning
how to read, Jimmy.
And my favorite part about
reading -- you know what it is?
-No.
-Finding out what happens
at the end of the book.
So, tell me, what happens at
the end of your book?
-Well, it's not really about
the end of the book.
-Yes, please. Por favor.
-Yeah, but it's more about
the journey that you take.
-Sure, sure, sure.
Okay, yeah. Mm-hmm.
-But, like,
do you want to go to the beach
or do you want to go to
la playa?
-Ooh, la playa.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But how does it end?
Tell me. How does it end?
Yeah, mm-hmm.
So exciting! Jimmy, come on!
-Do you want to play
soccer or play fútbol?
-Oh, she's so cute.
Look at that.
Look at that pollito lindo.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah,
but how does it end?
How does it end?
-Do you want to go to school
or do you want to go to
la escuela?
-La escuela.
Jimmy, Jimmy, look at
the escuela with the campana.
-Yeah.
-With the backpack.
Jimmy...
-Yes?
-...do you know where
I really want to go right now?
-Where?
-To the end of the book,
por favor!
I'm so excited!
-Alright, alright.
The end of the book says,
"Let's say good night.
Tomorrow's another day."
You can read this again.
-Let me see.
-This time, pollito will play.
-Aww! Pollito!
-Pollito! It's cute.
-So cute.
-And that's the end.
Then you can finally see
the end is --
-Let me see. Let me see.
Ah, the end.
-Fin -- the end.
That's it right there, yes.
-Oh, Jimmy!
-Thank you for
helping me, Rosita.
-Oh, I love you so much.
Can I take it home?
-Yes, of course
you can take it home.
-And can you please read it
to me later on, again?
The whole thing?
-I will FaceTime you tonight
and read you a book.
-Okay, at what time?
Because I have to go to bed
at 8:00.
-I know.
Already, it's past your bedtime.
-I know. What am I doing here?
-What are you doing here?
-Oh, my goodness!
-You have to get back to
"Sesame Street."
-Yes, I have to --
You know what?
The count says hello.
It took him forever
to say goodbye.
I mean,
to say hello and goodbye.
So I just run out.
So I'm going to go now.
-You're going to go? Bye.
Rosita, so great to see you.
And thank you. You can come by
whenever you like.
-Oh, thank you.
Can I take two markers?
Let me put my book down here.
I need some markers.
-You want these markers?
-Yeah, and I think
I need a new microphone.
But I'm going to leave it there,
because I don't have
any more hands.
So can I come back later
for the microphone?
-Yes.
-And Elmito wants some gear.
Do you have anything there?
-My mug?
-Yeah, but it has --
No, never mind.
Okay, I'm going to go.
-You can take --
-But...
-I have nothing else
to give you.
-I'm going to go down
the stairs now.
-You're going to go down
the stairs. Bye.
-I love you.
-I love you, too. Bye.
Oh.
-iAdios!
♪♪
-Aww! I got
a cute kiss from Rosita.
Come on.
Guys, "Sesame Street's"
53rd season
debuts November 3rd
on Cartoonito on HBO Max.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Bye, Rosita!